hello and welcome to playstation grenade
it's time for another meet the voice
actors episode and this time we are
looking at the superhero extravaganza
which is marvel's avengers
if you've ever heard a voice in a video
game and thought where do i know that
voice from
this is the series for you as marvel's
avengers is an ever-expanding universe
of superheroes
i'd like to know who is your most
anticipated character
for me it's gambit one day mona me but
i'm getting ahead of myself
today we'll dedicate this episode to the
og six playable superheroes
starting with tony stark do the avengers
pose a danger to society that was the
question bruce
that was the question iron man is played
by video game royalty nolan north
so we'd like to have you played tony
stark iron man yeah yes
uh you know everybody always portrays
him as this super confident character
i think it's a mask for him i think he's
one of the most vulnerable guys i
guarantee you've heard his voice before
it's usually recognizable a mile away
let's break down a few without a doubt
his most recognized role is that of
nathan drake in the playstation title
uncharted i made a promise that i was
done with this life
over the span of 10 years nolan brought
drake to life with such epic lines as
face a genius you've been played
the character and series is so renowned
that there is currently a film on its
way
starring tom holland who also plays one
of tony stark's closest allies in the
avengers movies
it's a small world after all i'm calling
it now nolan will make a cameo in that
movie
but back to mr north's resume and cv did
you know he plays deadpool in numerous
video games
it's me deadpool marvel anti-hero
extraordinaire and over on the dc
side of things he has voiced lego
superman says what now
jazzbot remember the floating ghost
thing in destiny it was originally
voiced by peter dinklage but then nolan
swooped in and re-recorded everything
he's a hard-working guy don't do that
don't do that in tv and film he can be
found in many animated classics like
american dad
rick and morty and get this in 2019
he played terence in the angry birds
sequel
parents where are the kids i went all
the way back to the start of his
glistening career and found that back in
2005
nolan played hades in god of war the
thing that makes this even cooler
is that north reappeared in the series
13 years later to play the character of
modi
and where do you think you're going oh
no
brother the little freak's got a bow
what are we gonna
do and he did this alongside another
godlike voice actor
troy baker who plays magni surrender
the old father demands it and you've
guessed it already
troy baker is here in marvel's avengers
playing the non-green version of the
hulk
aka dr bruce banner she can be
fixed she can't be cured
i've done the experiments i've checked
her dna over and over and over again
you and i created the perfect disease
troy is an actor who has popped up in
half the episodes we've made of meet the
voice actors
bruce is just such a cool character a
lot of people are really
quick to bring out the big green but i
think that
that bruce is a super complex character
he's fun
and i've never played him before he was
the main antagonist in death stranding
he played the greatest surrogate dad
ever and occasional golf caddy in the
last of us
and only last month he picked up the
role of agent johnsy in the juggernaut
fortnight can you can you hear me here
you hear me troy is another actor
steeped in superhero voice acting
history
voicing batman in lego dc shazam and
batman family matters
you are not the real bad man really but
check this out
he played batman and the joker in the
greatest mashup you will hear today
batman versus the teenage mutant ninja
turtles
i am sugar take them down we need
answers
you're welcome to try back in 2015 troy
voiced the enigmatic ocelot in the
fantastic metal gear solid 5.
don't bother trying to dampen the recoil
you do that with a revolver
and the breakout role which blew
everyone's mind was as the evil dictator
pagan min
in far cry 4 but that dude was on top of
his fashion game
i recognize those eyes anywhere
to go back to his relationship with
nolan north did you know
like i've already mentioned they played
magni and modi in god of war
they played another set of brothers
nathan and sam in uncharted
and they even started a youtube channel
together named retro replay
before something happened between the
two which has remained secret
ever since but troy has left the channel
that makes me sad but they are the
world's biggest and most well-known
voice actors
and i dare say ego has a little bit to
do with it who are you people again
before we get sidetracked by drama
here's something you may not know
the hulk version of bruce banner is not
played by troy baker
oh no that privilege goes to darren de
paul
darren is renowned for his screaming
abilities and over-the-top acting
actually i am reinhardt
but when required he's got the subtle
skills when needed
the role which i know him from is
revenant in apex legends
[Music]
scream make sure everyone can hear you
now let's take a look at black widow
played by another acting behemoth
laura bailey oh all right
hey that thing you had me do with the
storm drain cover pretty badass
what is very relatable about natasha is
she's
extremely capable but she's at the core
she's
human this is not bailey's first time
playing black widow she's actually done
it for seven years straight now
in the avengers assemble tv series and
marvel's future avengers
let's find out here's a cool point to
note the uncharted series which stars
both nolan north and troy baker
well guess what guess who played nadine
ross in a thief scent
none other than laura bailey here she is
hurting nolan north i mean nathan drake
okay wait wait you and your brother have
proven yourselves the more capable
treasure hunters on the island shame
we're not on the same side
and wait there's more troy doesn't get
out of this unharmed
laura also played abby in the last of us
part two
i wasn't a huge fan of that character so
i made a video of abby
kicking the bucket as we're here for
marvel's avengers let's look at other
super roles laura has had in the past
she played super girl in injustice 2.
i've never seen her so
cold-blooded and let's talk about the
real superhero everyone needs in their
life
bayley played the legendary mary jane
watson
in the monumentally brilliant spider-man
on ps4 i think you're gonna be an
amazing dad someday
at the right time laura bailey has been
adding her voice to awesome products
since
1986 and to me she will be remembered
forever
as trunks in dragon ball z dragon ball z
zed
z see whatever you like don't you worry
you'll feel it soon enough our next
avenger
is the cap himself steve rogers played
by jeff shine
tony there was something buried deep
beneath the bay
somehow linked to the reactor working
its way to the surface every minute
one of the things i think is cool about
cap is i never feel like he
uh he necessarily wants to be a leader
he accepts that he is
jeff is another actor we've recently
looked at as he plays carlos olivier in
the resident evil 3 remake
earlier in 2020. jeff is still
relatively new to his voice acting
career in video games at least
and donning those weird capture spandex
suits
anyway his first role came in 2014 in
the game smite playing
road rebel hercules quality name you
couldn't handle the things i've seen
from then he added voices to call of
duty and lego dimensions before taking
the role of javier
in the walking dead look i know i'm
probably not the best person to talk to
about that stuff
before the next avenger is a god amongst
men
thor played by travis willingham ah
apologies you're very small and hard to
see
there is no need to cower before a son
of odin though i
understand the impulse having an
original story to tell as well
what they've done at crystal dynamics is
great so i think everybody's gonna be
pretty stoked
travis has been around and working since
1989
and like laura bailey he got his break
with dragon ball dubs
his first role in video games came in
2003 and the gamecube era
playing tahu in the lego bionicle game
does anyone remember that
in terms of superhero voices he should
sound familiar to many marvel fans
as he's voiced thor since 2013.
funny thing is before that he played the
hulk and human torch
and mastermind and mr fantastic and
doctor doom
and venom wow he's dedicated to the
superhero life
back in 2009 he played guile in street
fighter 4 the ties that bind
and like usual there's a wow roll in
here any tekken fans in the house
well did you know that travis is the man
announcing the matches in tekken
6. round one
fight the bad news is tekken 6 was 13
years ago
i feel old again
and finally the avenger no one expected
back when the game was announced
and the character is so well written
that she's many people's favorites in
2020.
kamala khan played by sandra saad
i mean superheroes were my world and
i figured if i could just i could just
win that fan fiction competition you
know
when i found out i was going to play the
role of kamala khan i was like
are you kidding i'm an avenger sandra is
currently having her breakthrough year
in video game acting
thanks to this lead role as kamala and
an appearance in call of duty modern
warfare
as nadia with small parts in rage 2
fallout 76 and the elder scrolls
the future looks bright for sandra and
she has the perfect personality to be a
huge star
in this field so keep an eye out for her
so there we have it the first six
avengers in marvel's avengers with black
panther two versions of hawkeye
and spider-man coming soon i'm guessing
part two won't be too far behind
if this was your type of video a like
really helps and a comment would mean
the world to me
thanks for your time i'm adam from
playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you